- It's another rad mama hour again
give it up for the moms of the world.
I don't know about y'all,
but I have been dreaming
of some mommy time in the sun these days
especially as things
slowly start to open up.
I've learned the zoom as they say.
Yup. They wrote it in there.
Okay. I know. It's just Zoom.
They're making me sound old.
That's fine.
I'm with it.
Look, the zoom. I've
mastered the face time.
I can check in with my
kiddos and love them
from afar for a couple of days.
We all need it.
I'm thinking beach please. Yes.
Yes. So here to tell us
about some of the best mommy getaways.
Let's welcome back the
travel Mama, herself,
Emily Kaufman everybody!
- Hey, hi everybody! Hi
Kelly! It's good to be back.
- You always look so beautiful.
Like so put together,
like how I envisioned
myself looking when I leave my
house, but it doesn't happen.
So what's your first recommendation
for moms who want a summer escape?
- Moms are so busy taking
care of everybody else
that they don't really
take care of themselves.
- Preach.
- It's a wonderful way
to go away and get some terrific RNR
with the Cove Atlantis on
paradise Island in The Bahamas.
This is a wonderful resort spread out
where there's luxurious white sand beaches
cabanas that face both
the pool and the beach.
Celebrity inspired
award-winning restaurants
and adults only pool.
And it's a great place to go.
So mom can let somebody else
take care of her for a change.
- I love that. I'm going to be so sad.
This whole episode, just closing my eyes.
Wishing I was there.
- I was want to mention that
the Cove is making it very easy
for people when they travel
because The Bahamas
requires a health visa.
You have to upload a negative COVID test
before you go and at the Cove.
They give free testing
for the people who are
staying on property.
And they also give you a free
test because the CDC requires
that before you board a
flight to go back home.
So you've got everything
right there under one roof.
- Yeah, that's great actually.
Well, good news.
Emily's not just telling
us about ideal vacation.
She's helping us give some away.
So anyone in the house seats
interested in an escape
to The Bahamas?
Does anyone? Everyone
lit up. Okay. All right.
Let's get our light
shows shuffle underway.
When I say go, the lights
will flash on random audience
members until they land on someone.
Whoever it stops on is
getting the ultimate vacation
which includes a seven day
romantic getaway to the Cove
at Atlanta's and The
Bahamas you'll experience.
Luxurious accommodations
and daily breakfast for two.
Let's get to this y'all Joe.
Ready? Go!
Who will it be? Who will it be?
(Kelly imitates an air horn sound effect)
Who will it be? All right. Where's it at?
All right! Woo!
All right so, what's your name?
- My name's Elaina!
- Well, now you're
getting seven days of fun.
So you will enjoy.
- Oh my gosh. Oh my
gosh. Thank you so much.
- Absolutely. I love that accent as well.
All right, so what's next?
- You'll get many people who want to have
a tropical exotic vacation
but they're not quite ready
to leave the country.
And Hawaii is a terrific
place to visit for that.
Now the Grand Hyatt resort
and spa on the Island
of Kauai is one of my
favorite pool areas ever.
You could see yourself floating
in a saltwater lagoon
with an adult beverage
or enjoying Pacific
Hawaiian food at tide pools
restaurant and Kuwait has
so many great ways to be
in the great outdoors.
And Hawaii has a safe
travels protocol in place.
Meaning you have to upload a
negative COVID test 72 hours
before you go, you receive a QR code.
That's sort of your admission
into your airline, your
hotel, your different things.
And I flew on Hawaiian airlines
which made this completely
seamless and easy.
Plus you feel their Aloha spirit.
The minute you get on the plane.
So, you know, you're on a vacation.
- Yes. You get laid
right when you get there.
It's awesome.
That's right. I had to do it.
That's right, I'm still fifteen.
Would any of you want
to get away to Hawaii?
Anybody? Probably no one,
no one. Yep. Okay, okay.
Well this resort is - oh, the band! Yes!
This is for a six night luxury getaway
to the grand Hyatt Kauai
resort and spa in Hawaii.
You'll enjoy spectacular ocean views
great restaurants and a
championship golf course.
Plus airfare is courtesy
of Hawaiian airlines.
Hawaii's largest and
longest serving airline.
Let's give another trip away.
I'm just saying I've been to this hotel.
You're gonna have a
good time. Joe, hit it!
(Kelly imitates an air horn sound effect)
Where's it going? Where's it going?
Where's it going? Who shall it be?
Who shall it be? Who is it?
Oh my God look at her! (Kelly laughs)
Oh, I'm so excited
because you're so excited.
So what's your name?
- I look like I'm going
to cry. My name is Amber.
- Oh Amber, have you ever been
to Hawaii - or Kuwait rather?
- No.
- Oh you're gonna love it!
It's so much fun.
I've actually stayed where you're staying
and it's so beautiful.
You're going to love it.
I suggest the ATV tours too.
They're very cool.
And it's like where
they did Jurassic park.
You can like drive through.
There's like a rope swing.
You feel like Indiana Jones.
It's very magical.
Anyway. I hope you have so much fun.
- Thank you so much.
- Absolutely. Oh, I love
when they get that excited.
Well, thank you so much, Emily.
We love having you here.
- You happy mother's day to you Kelly!
- Oh Happy Mother's Day, yes.